next a report from reuters um this is
kind of some real journalism also so big
i'm i'm
i continue to be shocked uh this is a
maybe a good day for mainstream
journalists they don't have very many
but here's one
some reuters reports u.s representative
alexandria quezo cortez became one of
america's most prominent progressive
democrats with her calls to tax the
wealthy
and spend heavily to fight climate
change now she is investing heavily in
her online store selling t-shirts
sweatshirts
and other merchandise with her name aoc
initials or slogans including tax the
rich
and fight for our future efforts aimed
at both fundraising and building the
second term lawmakers profile nationally
her campaign paid political merchandise
firm financial innovations
which operates her online store and
supplies merchandise more than 1.4
million dollars in the first six months
of 2021
according to campaign disclosures to the
fec late last week
that's more than many lawmakers spent on
their entire re-election effort during
that period
and nearly double her payments made over
the prior two years to financial
innovations
um a cranston rhode island firm that
specializes in political merchandise for
democrats political t-shirts and
campaign swag were once again
uh okay so i think we get the idea there
she's
spending one and a half million dollars
investing in merchandise that she's
then going to sell including merchandise
that ironically says tax the rich
now sean spicer pointed this out
former white house spokesman now a
newsmax host host
pointed this out on twitter and aoc
responded it pointed out
the hypocrisy here that you're a critic
of capitalism
you're socialists vowedly so and
here you are engaging in capitalism
what do you know turns out you actually
like making money
you just don't like it when other people
make it you want to be the one who makes
it
aoc responded to the criticism though
and said not sure if you know this sean
but transactions aren't capitalism
capitalism is a system that prioritizes
profit at
any and all human slash environmental
cost
but for what it's worth our shop is
unionized doesn't operate for profit and
funds projects like free tutoring food
programs
and local organizing okay so
so so that's what it is
yeah i would have thought that if you're
in in the free market making a
transaction with somebody else
offering them a good or service in
exchange for money that's a transaction
i would have thought no that's exactly
what capitalism is actually
that's at the most basic level that's
free market capitalism i have a
good or service i offer it to you you
choose to buy it
with your own money i take your money i
have it now
that i'm no economist but when i think
of
at the most basic level what a free
market capitalism is that's that's what
it is
but she says no no no no no so you can
do that and it's not capitalism because
capitalism
uh is a system sort of like that but it
prioritizes profit
at any and all human and environmental
cost
so she's saying i am i am making a
profit but it but it's
it's i'm not prioritizing that over
everything else it's only if you
prioritize it over everything else that
it counts as capitalism
which is just a long way of saying it
all goes back to
i can do this but i don't think other
people should
i can trust myself with money
my own money your money
which i should be given whether it's
because you're buying a t-shirt or i
just take it from you
i'm a good person i can be trusted with
money not the rest of you because you're
bad people
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content